started the season in the starting  lineup has come off the bench  the last four games the team has  responded he continues to do what he is  doing  24 seconds to play here in this first  half  oh did you see what happened i i'm  trying to figure that out so tyler here  was going to take a quick shot  knowing that andre iguodala was coming  in the game but they didn't do it  so he just took the shot and now kennedy  maureen officiating crew saying you only  have one shot left  he didn't think they were going to count  that first when he was messing around as  a shot  [Applause]  i just seen a lot of stuff in my 20 plus  years  that one right there is the first time  i've seen that  i so you correct me if i i've never seen  a player be able to practice the free  throw  i have i've never seen it i saw it there  and i'm like that's bizarre to me